It was meant to be and I think is the symbolic center
of the university.
we probably see more people passing through here
in the course of a year
than almost any other space that I can think of at Harvard
We're not just a museum to the war dead of WWI who
were brought through
but we're a large and lively
congregation and it's the natural place that people
turn to
when there is trouble
or sorrow
or celebration
I think people are, especially
in large institutions like this
need a place of centering
they need a place where they can bring both their
sorrows and their joys
so this is one of those few places, I can't think
of many people celebrate in the library
and you may not be particularly thoughtful
on soldiers field but
this church
with the emphasis upon
a commemoration of sacrifice, young lives
all sorts of promise. So this is a place where
freshmen are welcome, these are the steps on which
commencement is held
there are very few buildings
and programs at Harvard that are hospitable in this way
and I think that's why people turn to us,
they recognize
that they need it
and we certainly encourage it, we want it to happen.
The original connection was that the dead
should always be present among the living, that the
two should be together
and that happens most perfectly at reunions
when at the center of every reunion is a memorial service
and then somebody said to me
it's really nice to know that when I'm dead,
somewhere somebody will call out my name,
and this is that place.
And I want it always to be the case here. And as Harvard becomes
ever more diverse and complex
I hope that this place will continue to be
the heart of its operations, and I believe it can be.